[Music]
danny vilnav's dune was definitely one
of the hits of this movie year still the
blockbuster based on the book series of
the same name by frank herbert in fact
only showed part of what we know from
the original books today we want to talk
about dune part 2 and over a small
preview of the sequel which will be
groundbreaking for the further
development of the dune franchise we'll
cover lots of events from the books from
theatrical film and from david lynch's
old movie so of course there is a
correspondingly high risk of spoilers
in dune we were already introduced to
the gigantic universe during the almost
two and a half hour duration the story
takes place in the year
10191 and deals with the power struggle
for control over the galactic empire of
mankind the focus is on paul atreides a
smart young man who cannot quite grasp
yet what his great destiny will turn out
to be the son of lady jessica and
ukulele to atreyus first is not really
finding his way around his new home
planet of erikas and is soon confronted
with the death of his father and his
escape with his mother from the forces
of the hostile harkonnen family at the
end of the film he meets the girl johnny
whom he had previously only seen in his
dreams and joins the native freeman the
ending of part one is not as a prop as
it might seem at first glance given a
large scale story the first movie
covered roughly half of herbert's book
dune and concludes when halsey trades
his moral as non-existent and looks like
an outnumbered battle a ritual by which
paul and his mother gain the respect of
the freeman has already been depicted in
the film paul fights james in a knife
fight to the death as the laws of the
freeman demand the second ritual on the
other hand did not occur which is why we
assume that we will see it at the
beginning of dune 2. this time is the
turn of paul's mother jessica as she has
to drink from the water of life however
contrary to its euphoria's name the
water of life is not a tasty magic
potion but the poisonous excretion of a
young said warm ground in water the
procedure has to do with the beliefs of
the fremen because worms play a major
role there they're characterized by
great duality since the warm can
represent both god and satan by drinking
the water she becomes the reverent
mother of the fremen a kind of spiritual
leader as reverend mother she must then
transform the water of life into a
harmless drug that the fremen enjoy to
consume at their gatherings but how does
the story go on in dune 2. those who
know the books will know that after
jessica's ritual there is a big time
jump here director of olaf should be
particularly careful not to rush the
story
after all that was one of the major
flaws of the first movie adaption from
1984 so it may well be that they will
take their time to depict the arrival
and further life of paul and jessica
with the fremen in particular we have in
mind the birth of paul's sister alia who
has already gained consciousness in her
mother's womb through the water ritual
and possesses special powers she is also
the girl with the blue eyes of whom paul
has some visions because of his
successful fight against james paul is
called usual by tripolita stilgar it is
translated as the strength of the base
of the pillar stillger will later become
a loyal companion and important advisor
to the main character the final
acceptance by the fremen is then also
expressed in a completely new name for
paul and that is
in contrast to usual this is his common
name with which everyone addresses him
from now on actually in arabic a similar
word means teacher a second story aspect
that unfortunately comes up far too
short in the book is the initial love
affair between paul and shani which also
took its course during the great time
jump one could certainly fill hours with
the unfolding of the relationship
between paul and shauni up until the
birth of their first child however the
challenge will be to find the balance
between a debunked love story and
interesting story details either way the
book picks up quite late after the time
jump in addition to his personal family
happiness paul grows more and more into
a leader position among the fremen and
his initially not yet developed strength
also becomes increasingly powerful he is
seen by the feminist the great savior
that has been repeatedly prophesied to
them and many of the visions that have
long haunted paul will also eventually
coalesce particularly with all the spies
the freeman consumed paul's powers
continue to increase as a result paul
becomes sort of overpowering and is
capable of looking into the past and the
future as well as seeing all the events
of the universe at the same time it will
be a special treat to see paul riding
the true fan favorites later in the film
namely the sand worms when he then also
drinks the water of life which can
actually only be survived by women his
powers will complete and he will be
ready to finally face baron harkenen
interesting is the future of the
character gurney helg embodied by thanos
actor josh brolin the duke's umura is
also paul's trainer and has trained him
for the adverse conditions of the desert
planet similar to the mantid thuberhavat
it is unclear whether and how they
survived the harkonnen's insidious
attack in the book the method is later
forced into service by baron harkin as
his own mounted peter debris was in fact
killed by duke later due to a mix-up a
different fate happens to gurney as he
surprisingly survives the big battle and
devotes himself to alive as a spy
smuggler in the course of the story he
also meets paul and jessica again who
let's say he's not too fond of
particularly with the letter he finds
himself at odds there are of course more
presumed dead characters with
questionable destinies on the one hand
there is planetary ecologist lead kinds
who appears for the first time as a
woman in vilnav's film adaption unlike
in the book and in the 1984 film
according to the book she is indeed dead
but then again the question can be
raised whether will enough perhaps
recast her for the reason of having her
appear in the second part as well in any
case the director can be credited with
that much artistic freedom in a movie
adaption that is otherwise very close to
the book even more likely is a
reappearance of duncan idaho who was
possibly merely wounded but not killed
in the attack on ericus the likable
character who is also played by the
popular jason mamoa at least appears to
have a future in the world imagined by
frank herbert he no longer appears on
the old dune film but he does celebrate
his return as gola in the second book
strictly speaking however duncan is no
longer alive because agola is an
artificially created human being who
preserves the memories of an individual
and thus lets him live on in a certain
way someone who was missing from the
book as shadow iv the emperor of the
entire universe and undoubtedly one of
the most powerful figures perhaps vilna
deliberately withholds him from us in
order to then abruptly seek him on paul
and his companions as a new villain the
comparison to david lynch's movie is
interesting here because there the
emperor has a normal appearance anyhow
quite a few casting possibilities are
circulating on the net from michael
fassbender and jared harris to match
mikkelsen or ralph vines this slim
elegant man with a cold eyes described
in the book would be perfectly suited
for many actors but there is no reliable
information about casting yet all things
considered it can be said that dune part
1 takes place in a relatively short
period of time compared to the possible
plot of part 2. the difficulty with the
sequel is making a meaningful connection
between the end of the first movie and
the beginning of the second between paul
and jessica's joining the freman and the
big attack on the parent or even the
emperor later on a fair amount of time
passes in between will never has to
accommodate a giant plethora of events
or at least cut them down enough in
order to do justice to the scope of the
book and an adequate big screen
adventure at the same time jessica has
to face the ritual paul becomes muad
deep and learns to ride sandworms and
then simultaneously they have to prepare
for the grand finale of the second part
and include many of the aforementioned
characters anyway we are very excited
about tuned part 2 and look forward to
the planned release in almost 2 years
time on october 20th 2023
this was our latest original on dune
part 2. what do you expect from the
sequel do you agree with our analysis
and most importantly who would you like
to see in the role of the mighty emperor
feel free to let us know in the comment
section see you next time
[Music]
[Music]